we have a voicemail number and that
number is
219 to david p
i spoke earlier this week speaking of
wasting time
i spoke earlier this week about the
possibility
of the left taking advantage of joe
biden defeating donald trump
to actually get things done from the
standpoint of progressive politics and
of course
democrats taking over the senate would
be a big part of that here's a caller
who is skeptical to say the least that
that's something democrats are going to
do take a listen
david are you serious you've got to be
joking
you're giving the democratic party as it
is right now
way too much credit for the game for
being able to hypothetically
take advantage of the dissension among
the ranks and on the republican side
if that was the case we would have done
it already it ain't gonna happen
unless we first address the defaults in
this party
you have to get rid of the centrist
democratic leadership
otherwise everything else is an academic
exercise
and we don't have that much time for
academic talk anyway
being how fist a copy the people on the
far right are becoming
the brown shirts are coming we better
beef up so listen
i i don't disagree generally speaking
that the centrist elements of the
democratic party are standing in the way
of progressive change and reform and i i
i agree there however you know the the
the idea that democrats have done
nothing the 2018 midterms were really
good for democrats in the house of
representatives now the the map
in the senate was not favorable to
democrats but
there were some in in 2018 in the
midterms this was one of the biggest
moves away from republicans and two
democrats in any recent congressional
election
and a lot of the people that won on the
democratic side in 2018
were some of the more progressives
member members of the house of
representatives so that was
that was the last real opportunity when
there have been state elections we've
seen states like virginia move left
we've seen a lot of different states
move left
and now this is the next opportunity so
let's not um
let's not get ahead of criticizing
democrats
there was an opportunity in 2018 and it
went
almost as well as it could possibly have
gone let's now see what happens in
november and then go from there the
skepticism i understand and it makes
sense
but to say that there has been no
advantage taken
from the way that trump has sort of
divided the republican party 2018 is a
pretty good example of democrats making
some significant gains now of course we
don't have the senate uh
on our side and we don't have uh the
white house
so there's a limited amount that can be
done let's see what happens if democrats
are able to take the white house
in uh november and potentially take the
senate if not this november in november
of 2022
then we will analyze and go from there
uh we have a great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk
about um derek chavin uh who has been
charged
in the killing of george floyd also
being charged for tax evasion
and i've got a bunch of other great
stories for you on the bonus show two
ways to get instant access number one
become a member at jointpakman.com
number two
become a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show and you will then get
the bonus show
every single day it's a beautiful thing